country music currently has all the
Limelight and mainstream music we're
seeing so many people release top
charting country records we're seeing
post Malone Luke comes shabzi Kelsey
ballerini all these people make really
really good versions of country that
feel like pop songs but have country
elements and it's something that we've
never really covered on this channel
before so in this video today I want to
show you how to make a modern country
song in the style of people like post
Malone shabzi Luke comes biley Zimmerman
any of those kind of like new country
not quite Stadium country but Rock
elements pop elements country elements
and by the end of the video you should
be able to dive in and make yourself a
summer country Banger so let's go ahead
and let's dive in but before we do my
name is Austin you're watching make pop
music if you like this video please make
sure that you like it and leave a
comment down below We Do videos like
this every single Friday so make sure
that you subscribe so you don't miss
next week's other than that if you want
to support us after the video head over
to our website make poop music.com we
have sample packs preset packs courses
free products all kinds of really really
cool stuff over there but let's dive in
and let's take a look at this song So
for Country the first thing that I want
to do is actually start with some kind
of acoustic guitar so I have a little
tailor 214 CE right here and I'll write
it and then track it off of camera but
I'm thinking we have a capo on two so
maybe just like
a something like
that nice little chord progression super
simple
[Music]
I'm going to track that up on my actual
tracking chain and then we'll go from
there so here we go I went ahead and
double tracked it and we have one pan
70% left and one pan 70% right together
they sound like this this is just my
guitar going into my mic chain so the L
audio Eden the Rupert Eve uh new channel
strip and then an 1176 and an LA 2A so
let's go ahead and hear what these sound
like with absolutely nothing on
[Music]
them they're super clean I like my
acoustic guitar tracked about a foot
away I did a whole video on recording
acoustic guitar so check that out so we
don't have to spend too too much time on
it but in terms of mixing this I'm going
to do something pretty straightforward
so there's a new plugin for make believe
that actually just came out today not
sponsored or anything but I got to beta
test it maybe you'll see some presets in
there from me very very soon if they're
not already there but this is basically
a channel strip which kind of does
everything I need for acoustic guitar so
we're doing a little bit like a half DB
boost at 10K we're actually doing like a
2 and 1/2 DB cut at around 2 and 1/2k
and then we're doing a 5db cut of just
kind of like a low filter and then uh we
also have the compressor engaged right
here medium attack fast release uh depth
and thresholder just making sure that
it's touching
it there it is on the left side when I
engage it on both it just kind of clears
up some of that muddy low end
so that feels pretty good for now that's
kind of going to be the big Motif for
the verse let's go ahead and let's start
adding some drums on top of here for the
main drums I'm actually just going to
use these on shots that I have from a
kit called country hits I believe it's
by a friend of the Channel Austin Shan
so I'll try to link that if anybody
wants these but here's the kick here's
the
snare and then I also went ahead and
routed this out and
then and what I'm doing is basically
just processing the kick in the snare
with an instance of verb
suite for the snare it's at like 920
milliseconds kick room is a bit shorter
I believe we are at 778 milliseconds and
then just do a little bit of EQ but when
you play those
together it allows you to kind of
recreate that room sound so I'm going to
lay down some drums so the one shot pack
has symbols however I like my simple
super super round robin for something
like this I want it to feel like a real
kit so I'm still using those shells from
that country hit pack but I'm actually
using symbols from the goira kit right
here from mix wve this is mix wve has
been like my go-to for kids it's
definitely very Rocky in terms of like
shells so I'm really only using the toms
and the symbols but when I pop both of
those together we get
[Music]
this let's add a base I'm going to go
ahead and just add in like a wreck and
Boer base from contact so here's what
the base looks like I just have it on
the TW Weedman setting this bass
actually sounds so good for like country
music like this and I'm just using the
Palm mute version and we're just doing a
little bit of limiting and a little bit
of
[Music]
EQ it's just kind of cleaning up some of
those mids so that's feeling pretty good
I want to go ahead and flesh out this
verse with like maybe some lap steel and
some secondary guitars that can make it
feel a little bit bigger what I wanted
to do for guitar was add some kind of
like electric guitar that kind of does
like a lap steel thing so it sounds like
[Music]
this it's just my Fender Strat what I'm
doing to kind of give myself that lap
steel sound is compressing it a lot and
taking away quite a bit of
[Music]
transient and then using something like
Devil lock to really even get it even
more
[Music]
compressed that gives you that sustain
that you would hear in like a slide
guitar or a lap steel and then I just
found this preset Dawn Shores kind of
gives me the vibe I want and then just a
little bit of EQ kind of band passing
and it doesn't sound exactly like a lap
steel but it's definitely the
[Music]
vibe and then we just have these crunchy
pal mute
guitars for that I'm using Guitar Rig I
know last video I talked so much about
how I like neural DSP stuff um still
great for some reason this just has such
good like country American tones so I'm
just using this Blues fuzz preset with a
a couple little tweaks and then I just
have a double track right and left
guitar and then I wanted to make it
super country so I just found some kind
of like steel guitar one shot little
Loops out of
[Music]
splice and honestly that'll probably do
it for the verse I'll arrange it a
little bit more later but let's go ahead
and move on to the pre Chorus for the
preor I want to do a little bit of a
chord change so we've been doing
the I think for the preor let's try
something more like
this let's
[Music]
do something like that maybe like a
let's try that so here's what we have
for this riff again I'm using that mbsi
to do most of my stuff so we have it on
the mic so it's flat basically same
settings as our last guitar but for this
one I wanted it to feel a little bit
smaller so we're doing some band passing
to kind of give it that telephonic
effect and I have these 80% left and
[Music]
right so it's really cool I want to
layer over over some high strums on that
I did some high strums a lot of the time
when I work with acoustic guitar what
I'll do is I'll have little individual
tracks where I can do things like the
nbsi and like small processing and then
I'll have it sent to an actual group
robust so I can do any kind of big macro
processing here so you can see that I
get I do some pretty gnarly EQ moves
that's just to make sure that it'll sit
in the
mix if I took all that off
[Music]
just basically giving me a mid boost
especially in this right here we've got
some mids instead of cutting it we're
boosting it we're adding quite a bit of
air we're adding a ton of low end here
so before when we were cutting all the
low end out of those finger pick Parts
we're adding some of that back in now so
it feels a little bit thicker so let's
hear
[Music]
this let's go ahead and get some drums
working so I kind of want to do like a
four on the floor thing maybe we play
that with like some like
toms let's go ahead and program
something real quick here's what we did
for the drums here is all of the
[Music]
midi so it's definitely giving us a
littleit bit of a rise let's go ahead
and just add in the root notes on this
Palm mute base and now the Palm mute
base is cool it fills it out a
lot but I kind of want some electric
guitar in there just doing a little bit
of a counter Melody maybe we have this
like little lap steel Vibe going and
then I kind of want to put more of like
a little Slappy Western Lick in there so
here's the two licks that I want to show
you I have this little Western lick here
I actually am using the ton king so I'm
using their uh neural DSP tone king
imperial little bit of compression
little bit of dry from here nothing that
wild
some EQ just kind of taking out some of
those harsh mids and then some delay CH
and Reverb and it's this nice Slappy
little
[Music]
lick and then we have that same lap
steel setting from earlier that's panned
out to the
[Music]
right and as you can tell in the song
and in a lot of the country references I
was using they do a lot of stacking and
layering and panning out to the sides
but there's also a lot of
differentiation between the left and the
right so I don't have to double track
this Western lead I don't have to track
this lap steel twice I have my main
elements double tracked and panned out
but the rest of them I kind of want to
have special things happening on each
side so here's what it sounds like
[Music]
now I'm going to go ahead and find a
couple more like little lap steel
samples to add in there I think it might
help here's one that I found they're all
kind of from the Nathan Chapman Library
so if you're trying to make this I guess
go on splice and find
that it's really nice texturally layered
over
[Music]
everything that's feeling pretty good
for a precourse let's go ahead and get
the drawing for the chorus working I
think for this we're doing four on the
floor kick and just snare on the two and
four
just just to kind of give us a driving
Rhythm here is our chorus drums as you
can see kick and snare two and four very
very simple then we just have crashes
and some alt crashes over here just to
kind of Drive the Rhythm this is about
as simple as you can
get so that's feeling pretty good let's
go ahead and just lay the Baseline
Melody I think we're going to follow the
verse chord progression and I kind of
want to change the guitars a little bit
but let's go ahead and add the base for
the chorus we're actually going to swap
from the pal mute base to
[Music]
this and it's going to kind of follow
like a strumming pattern I think that's
what we're going to do on the guitar as
well
so let's go ahead and track up those
chords on
acoustic I think what is basically going
to be is basically a cad or
a what would that be we're on the second
K POS so basically just like
a uh CAD N I
believe G add
n and
then what are we doing we're doing
[Music]
there we
go and as far as coming up with these
Chords it's all by ear I'm not like a
big music theory
guy so that'll work we're going to
double track that so here is our
acoustic drums for the
[Music]
chorus just filling out the mids a
little bit there but tracking wise
sounded great we just double tracked it
I will say I went ahead and tracked up I
had copied and pasted the verse riff I
wanted to play around with that and do
something a little bit different so what
we're doing now is closer to
this instead of just straight
arpeggiating so it's the same Chords
it's just doing a slightly different
riff
[Music]
with the layered
guitar and then while I had the acoustic
out I just kind of had this like
acoustic Slappy little
[Music]
lead almost sounds like a fiddle again
this nbsi is really what I used on all
the Acoustics this thing I'm telling
y'all go demo this today I think Maple
Le literally just did it like right now
it's basically the console that they
used on Hotel California and Saturday
Night Fever and like a billion other
multi- multiplatinum if not Diamond
records from like the 607s and 80s this
thing is sick for acoustic guitars and
drums um then we're just filtering it
out a little bit with some EQ adding
some Echo boy and adding some
[Music]
Reverb that's my dry tone so we're
getting a pretty good signal on the way
in
[Music]
now what I want to do is track up These
acoustic guitars basically what's that
what that's doing with the strums I want
to do that on some cranky uh kind of
electric guitar here we go this is just
our electric guitar from the verse that
we used for the P mutes and I'm just
playing this
[Music]
open and I know what you're thinking the
tone sounds so bad in Solo and I tweaked
it for about 5 minutes off camera and
then realized let's just pop it in the
mix mix and to be honest the worse it
sounded in Solo the better it sounded in
a mix and vice versa when it sounded
great in Solo it was not sitting at all
and then I just went ahead and
duplicated
that played that on my Strat as well to
kind of layer with the acoustic and now
we go into this chor we have some little
[Music]
Flacks let's go ahead and get a little
lap steel going for like a counter
Melody here we
[Music]
go so that feels pretty good I'm going
to go ahead and start writing some
lyrics and and vocals now so we just
kind of have to get the vibe
first let's do
[Applause]
all right I'm going to put some lyrics
to that and then track up some vocals
let's move on to this uh little pre
chorus let's do Melody
first I kind of want to do something a
little bit faster
[Music]
all right so let's write these out right
let's do you fooled me
once but I let you fool me
twice all
right you fool me once but I let you
fool me twice
all right here's what we ended up for
the verse you fooled me once but I'd let
you fool me twice swear that i' do
anything to go back to that night down
on my knees I'm begging baby please left
me on the hook and I took the bait oh I
had this I didn't like it when I was
singing along all right let's move on to
the pre-
[Music]
chorus all right let's do
I keep running back to the
bottle thinking you come home by
[Music]
tomorrow let's throw in another country
little mad lib
uh let's do thought I
saw your pink Silverado pulling
up but but I know it's the liquor
hitting me
I keep running back to the bottle
thinking you'll come home by tomorrow
thought I saw your pink silver pulling
up but I know it's a li hit me let's do
sipping jacking but and some Jimmy
Bean bringing up all the goddamn
memories ahead of us
all right so let's try
that I
sawt
up I know
it's all right I'm going to go ahead and
write the chorus and just go ahead and
get vocals track so we have some time I
went ahead and tracked all the Vo so we
have everything right here so for the
verse we're actually going to do a
triple track lead let me show you what
this vocal sounding like with nothing on
it vocal chain is L audio Eden into new
uh Newton Channel strip 1176 R FD from
audio Escape opto compressor from audio
Escape here's what it sounds like you
fool me once but I let you fool me twice
little bit of EQ compression and dsing
some sins you fool me once but i' let
you fool me twice swear that I do
anything go back to that night we're
going to go ahead and layer that left
and right vocal as well just to kind of
thicken it you fool me once but I let
you fool me twice swear I do go back to
that night so we're kind of doing that
throughout the verses once we get to
this precourse the I keep running back
to the bottle I am adding a Harmony I
rning back to the think you home by
tomorrow thought I saw your pink silver
pulling up
but I know it's a li hit me sipping
jacking but Jimmy Bean bringing up all
the goddamn memories ahead of us in
terms of vocal production there's not
much happening it's literally just the
chain that I showed you here it's a
plate Reverb a room Reverb and a quarter
note delay and that is like legitimately
it it is by far the most simple vocal
production we've had on the channel for
how to make and forever in the chorus we
do layer this up a lot we have the lead
we have a lead dub for the left and a
lead dub for the right we have a
consistent pedaling Harmony for the left
and right that just kind of sits up
here that is panned out 67% left and
right and then we have a kind of
floating Harmony that's about 80% left
and
right so all together when we in love
spend in my truck driving down
the so that's pretty much it I'm going
to go ahead and throw on my mix bus
settings here's what we're doing on the
mix bus I'm just using gold clip to
basically clip some of the kicks and
snares and then I'm just using vbc red
to do a little bit of compression
actually like a good bit like 3db of
compression on the bus and then mix head
just to give me a little bit of
saturation I actually don't need Saturn
I can turn that off uh linen B normally
I don't have this really tone shaping I
just have this catching things but I
realize that a lot of country is not
nearly as like lowend sub heavy as I
produce and mix so I took the subs and
the lowend down a little bit boosted
those mids and then really just have Pro
uh Pro L2 doing a little bit of boosting
so I'm going to go ahead and kind of
show you everything that should be every
element what I did do for the structure
is I actually copy and pasted this
guitar over here and just added a little
rc20 just so there's something to give
us an intro then we go into an acoustic
version of the hook and then we go into
our verse where vocals are then the pre
chorus with vocals and the hook with
vocals so let's go ahead and listen this
should be everything all at once
[Music]
you fool me once but I let you fool me
twice swear that I do anything to go
back to that night down on my knees I'm
make baby please left me on the hook and
I took the B I keep running back to the
bottle thinking you go home by tomorrow
thought I saw your pink Silverado P
up but I know it's a li hitting me been
jacking but in some Jimmy Bean bringing
up all the goddamn memories out of us
they take me back to where we fell in
love spending summers in my truck
driving down the AL of for the weekend
let my family at the late saying that
you could away you were ding all the way
into the de so tell me what I've been
next next thing I know is that you left
I put my heart upon on my sleeve and you
tore it was everything you said a lot
was I just another guy with a million
little FS I
was left without the
warning then you go into a verse two
precourse 2 course 2 bridge but that's
pretty much it so essentially it comes
down to acoustic guitar electric guitar
layer up everything have some counter
Melodies big bass super super Punchy
drums and then just stack up your vocals
this is a really simple Arrangement
actually it's like strummed acoustic
guitar acoustic riff counter Melody
layer acoustic with electric and then
the base is like super super standard
drums are super simple so hopefully this
video helped if you like this please
make sure that you like comment and
subscribe let us know what artists you
want to see us make a video like in the
near future and if you want to support
us you can head over to make poop
music.com we have sample packs preset
packs midi packs we have a start to
finish production course we actually do
a similar song in the style of like
Indie poop and alternative it definitely
leans a little bit more like claro boy
Genius but we use real drums we use real
guitar real bass so go check that out if
you want to see something like this but
that takes 16 hours in real time other
than that let me know if you have any
questions down in the comments down
below I really really appreciate you
watching it and I'll see you super soon
with much more content but until then
much love peace